[Music]
Meryl Streep Meryl Streep Meryl Streep
Meryl Streep Meryl Streep she's won
eight times but nominated how many I've
just been nominated 789 times well 30
really eg first caught up with her for
nomination number 8 she was already a
seasoned pro by then important
recognition from the critics but it's
not her track record that makes her
queen of the Golden Globes that's so
much more reason number one she has
moments like this on the red carpet oh I
felt immediately better a reason number
two a woman comes prepared that they go
to the bar I remember a few years ago
you arrived at the Golden Globes and you
were hysterical you had brought your
flask and you whipped it out on our
platform babe I had that with me you do
a get with me right now this is Meryl
Streep's tradition this is for you
where's the bacon actually number three
Merrill's not afraid to say or do
anything would you like to go over to
the bar would you like to sit and be
comfortable okay just do that Oh sounds
great okay
all I'm worried about is that this is
gaffing I mean oh yeah I just realize
you can see completely through my dress
sometimes it's hard to be dressed up I
mean much more person who likes to be
relaxed
wearing something that's several
thousand years old that I had in high
school I think I've worked with
everybody in the room and that brings us
to number four she's earned the respect
of all of her peers like Annette Bening
who worked with her in postcards from
the edge I was so nervous I hadn't even
realized that they were rolling film
just because I was so nervous working
with her so it was a great lesson and
Tom Hanks who executive produced
Merrill's movie Mamma Mia look she puts
on a clinic every time every time you
sit down to watch her and finally Meryl
doesn't miss a party tell me how you're
gonna celebrate I'm gonna take my
daughter around to the parties on a
leash thank you thank you thank you
thank you thank you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]